foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
well do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I'm
Christina Ellis Ramsay personalities
joined today by my friend and fellow
Ramsey personality Rachel Cruz we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five give us a
call and let's chat let's go to the
phones first step we have Kaden calling
from Nashville Tennessee hey Kate and
welcome to the show
all right thanks for having me hey
thanks for calling how can we help
so I had a question about the most
efficient way to try to pay off your
home early
um you know I've heard you guys take
questions before about investing versus
paying on the mortgage and I'm really
kind of thinking
to be able to take advantage of that
extra percentage you would get by
investing but then still earmarking it
to pay off your home early so like take
that invest in a brokerage account let
it grow when that reaches the amount of
the principal left to kind of take it
out and pay off the house in one strike
basically to try to take advantage of
the math there but still the principle
behind paying off your home early and I
was just wondering what you guys
thoughts on that were
yeah I hear I hear what you're saying
and yeah I mean you would have to just
assume that the math is going to work
for you because when you're investing
you're investing for a long period of
time right so I mean I always say to be
in there for at least five years to
consider it investing and so if there is
cash that you have that can be thrown at
the mortgage though your principal goes
down
and you're going to be paying let like
as you keep going less and less with all
the interests and everything so I I like
the efficiency of not holding it in an
account hoping that you time the market
right when you need to take it out
because if you are prepped on paying off
your house in 2022 you wouldn't want to
take your money out because you're like
oh my gosh the Market's down I have to
wait till it recovers in order to
continue my financial plan so I would
rather you just put it towards your
mortgage as you go and then leave
investing for retirement and for
long-term savings versus using it as a
as a middleman before paying off the
house
yeah okay Caden how old are you
I'm 24. I you sounded young and I love
that you're even calling and asking this
question because it's like to be that
motivated and inspired early on is
amazing and if you pay off your house
just think about how much time you'll
have left to invest the fact that you
know you're doing this early hopefully
you can knock this out you know in half
the time half of 15 years and then it's
like you have the rest of your life to
invest so it's a great question for sure
but yeah and I see what you're saying
with the math and I and I get it but but
there is something Caden to be said that
when you start paying down your mortgage
and you start seeing that number get
lower and lower and lower and it's not
just sitting in account trying to play
another game there is that psychology
that we see over and over again that it
continues to cause you to be more
motivated causes you to maybe even make
more sacrifices than you thought to get
your house paid off that much faster and
that's the that's the advantage of
watching that principle go down as you
continue to pay it off does that make
sense
but yeah so I I mean that that's always
what I would recommend to continue
because again that investing game
for doing something like this it's like
well I don't want to pay off my house I
want to invest and then obviously he
said take the money out but if you don't
time it right or if it is if the
economy's not doing great you're not
going to want to take it out and pay off
your house and you're going to have a
mortgage for another two years yeah and
it's just tempting I mean to see that
money there and to not really have a
goal behind it there are people who are
amazingly disciplined and that could be
a thing but for a lot of people like you
said that's a great point that you'll
have all that money and then you're
thinking oh gosh maybe we need to
replace a car we need to like you have
it earmarked for the house but Life
Starts to happen and you think well we
can just use this cash for other things
that's a great Point too yeah it's
tempting sitting there all right next up
we have Nicole calling from Dallas Texas
hey Nicole Welcome to the show
hi thank you guys for having me of
course how can we help
yes so I had two two things
um I just finished esthetician school
and I was going to use that as like a
side hustle to generate some more income
and basically I'm now stuck between
renting a suite which here in Dallas
Texas
um Suites are usually running about
probably 1200 a month to 1500 a month
and that's kind of on the lower end and
I really am not in the place because I'm
in baby stuff number two um I just have
my car left to finish but I'm not in the
place to add an additional 1200 coming
out a month for a suite and I don't
really have a clientele yet because I've
just graduated
um so I'm stuck between that because I
was thinking about doing it at home but
then there's kind of like safety
measures with that yeah but I do know
some people that have done it in in the
very beginning of their career and you
know so that's that's one thing of just
getting your advice on what would you
kind of do with that and then number two
since I'm in baby step number two I have
an eight-year-old and it's really just
me filling out fear in which I should
kind of knock it down but I've been kind
of like sad sometimes because I'm trying
to do these steps and it feels like I'm
in a rush because I have an
eight-year-old and I want to put him on
like certain activities but I kind of
wanted your advice on that too because
there's some things I want to put him in
that you would have to pay for monthly
like tutoring he needs it for reading
and I don't really have much of a wiggle
room to kind of spin that and have him
keep going and doing that consistently
yes but I just don't want him to miss
out on childhood yeah I'm trying to save
money for sure well great questions
Nicole okay so we'll tackle the first
one
um so I know for a lot of people you
know I'm gonna use this as an example
Nicole because the girl that does my
hair she's in one of these private like
sweets like you're talking about you
know you walk into a building and
there's a bunch and people rent it out
it's exactly what you're saying and I
know for her even talking to her in her
business she did have to build up a
clientele by working at a salon for
about two years uh and then she had
enough of a clientele that she was able
and money
ongoing to be able to go and run out of
space and to ensure that she had enough
people enough clients to be able to do
that so have you thought about possibly
a salon option for for the time being
hmm yeah it's just the pay but I mean I
guess it's something I don't have to put
out anything because there's no risk
right and so even doing that for 12
months I think would be would be wise
because like you're saying it is a risk
and unless you can sublease maybe a day
or two from someone else that has a
suite I don't know how all that works
but maybe even if you just do it for one
day and it's not having to pay the whole
um where you work at a salon for most of
it and then you go and see if you can
you know if someone's not using their
space every Friday maybe you could
sublease that on just Fridays that's
good and start to do it on your own
yeah Nicole did you say that this was
your your side Hustle
yes I had went to school and that's what
I that I wanted what's your career right
now
um right now I worked in finance so with
the bank okay okay well I think that's
interesting especially since right now
this is a side hustle maybe that's kind
of just like you can create a five-year
Vision yeah where at some point this is
going to be your full-time Hustle but
right now like Rachel said maybe you can
get that clientele built up and then do
it full time and then do it full-time
but let it be a transition
um in the process and kids real quick
we'll hit on it because we both have
little ones Nicole he just wants to be
with you I think we get in this idea
that if they're not doing this sport or
doing that activity doing boy like that
they're gonna have this terrible
childhood they're not they're going to
be with you so prioritize if tutoring is
that have one maybe one or two things
that you prioritize that's the good for
him long term but his childhood I
promise is not gonna be taken away
because he's not doing a bunch of stuff
he wants his mom and you're doing a
great job Nicole well done
we'll be right back this is the Ramsay
show
[Applause]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
Christina Ellis joined today by Rachel
Cruz and we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to the phones next up we
have Theo calling from Phoenix Arizona
hey Theo welcome to the show
hello can you guys hear me okay yeah you
sound great how can we help
all right um
I just wanted to call and I've been
watching the show for a while and
um I'm 23 I've been working in a
warehouse since I was 19.
and ever since I was little I've always
dreamed about tattooing and now my
dreams are finally coming true I've been
an apprentice for the past six months my
wife's a saint she says go get it my
baby's the best she's two years old and
you know I just wanted to call today and
ask once I go on the tattooing full time
what steps should I take to make sure
that the rest of my life is set up where
I have a retirement I have savings I
have I have everything that this
warehouse job is kind of setting up with
the 401 and the
um medical and everything that a
warehouse drive would provide you that
way well where are you at now in terms
of your finances do you have any debt
uh thankfully all we have is our
vehicles I bought a 17 000 Titan and me
and my dad we do handyman on the side so
it's just not an ornament we pull
trailers we do a lot of jobs with it and
we have a
um nine thousand dollar
car payment for my wife because she
works full-time as well
and that's it no school debt no credit
card debt there's just these two in our
mortgage of course but what's your
mortgage
we got a house at 2 18. and the right
before the pandemic so our mortgage
payments are 11.5 every month
okay and then uh what is your take-home
pay gonna be with this new job
uh with
with tattooing it's very lucrative my
mentor's been tattooing over 10 years
and every month he takes home around
fifteen thousand dollars that's great
are you Theo are you going out on your
own or are you going to be working with
someone
I want to be staying in the same spot
that I'm premising under it's a great
shop in my town it's been voted best
shot six years in a row awesome I've
been very lucky to even get in because
I've seen him turn down countless and
countless of people trying to come in
I used to go to that shop when I was in
high school and when me and my wife
found out we were pregnant with our
first one I told him respectfully you
know I gotta take this warehouse job
full time which I did from 19 to Now 23
I'm still here what I love about it I
love my job I work in a Walmart
distribution I'm lead safety I I've took
on so many roles here and I love it I
absolutely love it it's a people's it's
a people business and so is tattooing
and that's great that's what I love
about it I'm excited for you I mean it
sounds like you're obviously extremely
passionate and you know what you want I
mean like it's like this is you've
enjoyed what you've done so far and
you've been grateful for that and I love
that spirit and you so um yeah that's so
great Theo so you're you're asking about
I think a couple of things you're asking
about retirement
and all of that so in at the since
you're working for a shop do they
provide do they have you know a 401k
plan do they have anything like that
when it comes to retirement
when you go into tattooing it's all on
you um it's his shot
and he's not my boss he's just the owner
okay okay and it's all on me at that
point so basically it's like I'm
starting my my own business yeah I hear
you from my space I hear you okay yeah
so what when they don't want to get
wide-eyed I don't want to be dumb yes no
we like that great questions I know so
great I'm calling you guys I I don't
know anyone that's really been
financially Smart in my life and I want
to make sure you know like I said I'm 23
I got a lot of living to do I'll make
sure I do it right yeah if every 23 year
old could call in man there'd be so many
30 year olds who didn't have major
Regrets We talked to so many people that
are just like if we would have known so
the fact that you're calling now Theo is
just wonderful and congratulations on
the new job that is so exciting and I
love the way that you've worked for it
you've persevered you set that goal
um are you familiar with the baby steps
no I'm not I I've heard of it on the
show but I've never really looked into
it I just wanted to call you guys do you
have do you have any savings for you
that's just
around that's not in retirement gesture
401K so nothing liquid okay so Christina
brings up a great point so walking
through the baby steps this is our
seventh step uh plan that really is
going to help guide you to do exactly
what you need to do and so that very
first step is to get a thousand dollar
emergency fund so I want you to do that
immediately that's the very first thing
you're gonna do and then number two
you're gonna start working your way out
of debt and it's going to be these cars
and you may look at the 17 000 Titan and
be like man I wonder like what Kelly
Blue Book would say do I sell it if you
can't pay it off it told me ten thousand
dollars and you know what Kelly Blue
Book ain't wrong she's old but that's
right she does her job she hauls the
kids around well our daughters one here
pretty soon yep so if you I would then
be paying off your wife's car first the
nine thousand get that paid off and then
be paying off your car and maybe you
guys look to say like man we want to get
out of debt so that we have our income
with all these car payments and maybe
you look at selling if you can't pay it
off in 12 to 18 months but that could be
what you decide and then you're going to
go look at a fully funded emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
and then we're going to start looking at
retirement okay so retirement is going
to be a little bit down retirement comes
last yeah it comes in the middle of the
plan so there's seven steps that comes
to number four step four will be 15 of
your income into retirement and just
tuck this away Theo because you probably
won't be contributing to retirement here
in the next maybe two three years while
you do these first couple of steps but
write down smartvestor Pro and go sit
down with one of our smart investor Pros
because they're going to be able to help
you when it comes to retirement because
you're going to want to do things like
open up a Roth IRA you know at that
point if you are still kind of out on
your own you know there's other options
for self-employed people to have plans
that are tax advantage for retirement so
be looking into that and then after that
it's kids college paying off the house
early all of it but if you hang on the
line
um Emily's gonna pick up and give you a
year-long membership to Financial Peace
University and every dollar plus are you
for real yes Theo are you kidding and
you and your wife I want you to sit down
and watch these videos because it's
going to be able to walk you through the
entire plan and you're going to learn
things like Insurance you're going to be
learning things you know even deeper in
investing when it comes to buying a
house I mean everything the basics of
what you probably Leo what every high
schooler should have learned before they
graduated high school this is this is
the class of like this is the basics of
how to win with money and here's the
deal Theo if you guys do it and what
Kristen has said earlier at your age if
you guys do this Theo you're you are no
doubt going to be everyday millionaires
very soon very soon especially if you're
making this kind of income you guys are
going to be able to completely change
your family tree and you said you've you
haven't known it you don't have anyone
in your life that financially you trust
in the field since she was four years
old and honor is the same thing I'm
Hispanic and yeah no one I have I have
nine uncles and I have I have like 10
grandfathers no one in my family's I
want to change that I want to show our
tree is you can do it yes yeah that's my
and that's the motivation that's for why
and and you just need that plan and I
can hear it in your voice you're gonna
do it I mean I I fully fully believe
that I don't get there I just wanted you
know in this life if you get help why
not take it that's right why not take it
and I I wanted to call you guys in today
you know and just see where to go
because past six months I've been
working 15 15 hour days every day that's
why I say my life's the same because I
only see her five minutes through the
day when I see her at work because I
come home at 12 o'clock at night usually
I'm out the door at eight o'clock to
drop off our daughter at daycare wow
Theo that's just amazing the fact that
you are 23 years old you are doing that
kind of effort you were having that kind
of perseverance I'm just waiting for the
day that you call in for the baby steps
millionaire theme hour like it's gonna
happen that's right that's right so
exciting and I just think it's such
motivation for all the young people out
there you know for everybody really even
if you're in your 50s and you're
listening and you're saying no one in my
family has ever been wealthy everybody
in my family has screwed up with money
and I want that to be different I want
to change our family tree you can do
that right now and if you're like Theo
and you don't know where you're at in
the Ramsay baby steps you can go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on get
started it'll take it's an assessment
that'll help you figure out where you
are and what you need to do next we'll
be right back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite com slash Ramsey today
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show we're
taking your calls today at triple eight
eight two five five two two five call us
if you have questions about your life
your money or really just anything if
you're working through a situation and
you want another set of ears give us a
call
all right Rachel I saw this article yeah
a few days ago about Mark Cuban and how
he's raising his kids and I think it's
just so interesting with a call we just
had from the 23 year old who's trying to
break generational poverty all these
different things and it's just so cool
because even though Mark Cuban is a
billionaire he stated in this article
that when he talks to his kids he says
after your health my number one thing
for you all is I don't want you to be
entitled jerks
so even even with tons of money billions
of dollars he's still prioritizing
making sure his kids have good money
values and principles I think it's
something that so many of us parents
worry about it's like no matter where
you come from you want your kids to be
smart with their money so many of us
graduated from college myself included
and there were so many things that I
just didn't know going out you know it
was like there's just all these sharks
in the water all these different
Temptations and you just get out into
the world and there's so many questions
um and so Mark he actually Lee says that
he told his kids that you know I'm not
just going to write you checks you don't
just get a credit card you can't just
buy whatever you want his kids are out
doing jobs they're working they're
making their own money if they want
something then they have to buy it
themselves and I just think that's so
cool you know we all come from different
money backgrounds we're all setting
goals of breaking generational poverty
or not having your kids be entitled
jerks yes yes and I know you wrote smart
money smart kids with your dad and I've
been working with students for years
going to college and I have seen so many
kids who didn't have the money
conversation and they end up drowning in
student loan debt because I didn't know
there was another option yeah yeah no
one talk to him about it and you said
that you know the student loan crisis
it's not just a money crisis it's a
parenting crisis it is you know the
result of a lot of parents being afraid
to talk to their kids about money or
just feeling like maybe they're not
qualified and it's just such an
important thing and you know we're both
moms of young kids and it's just it's
incredible how early these conversations
can start to come up and how curious
they are at such a young age so for all
of the parents listening you know when
is a good time to start having those
conversations with your kids yeah I mean
I you can have it as early as five years
old I mean I mean it's amazing what a
five-year-old I have a five-year-old we
have a three five and seven year old and
you know the encouragement I would have
for parents and this is what my parents
did for us is that it doesn't have to be
this big intimidating you know having a
money Summit every other weekend at the
house and we're all gonna like just sit
down and like be obsessed with money and
talk about mutual funds all the time
like it doesn't have to be like that at
all if you if you take this subject of
money in the ebb and flow of life and
just kind of pull your kids in it's
amazing what they learn from just life
and just having a little bit of
intentionality it doesn't have to be a
ton it really doesn't just enough where
you're like okay you know we are we're
communicating about it talking about it
and then that next big step is having
them actually interact with money and
having them do do chores around the
house if you have little ones yeah if
you have ones that are 15 16 17 that can
go have a job part-time doing that but
earning money I think is a great first
step where they start to learn this is
where money comes from money didn't come
from Mom and Dad it comes from working
and then once they make money when you
teach them to give to save to spend just
those three categories they do it
differently than if you were just if
they're handed allowance right like
every week you just get ten dollars or
five dollars because you were just here
uh but actually making them work and so
it's so funny Christina we're not
perfect at it by any means like Winston
and I I'm like man we should probably do
more that's like my job I might probably
be more intentional but it's funny to
already see our kids their personalities
because our oldest is like typical
oldest she reminds me of my sister even
she's a saver Amelia she's really she's
hard working like she will unload
dishwashers I mean she will go and like
that's like the dishwasher when yeah
after it runs she wants to unload it to
get you know we pay her a dollar for
that like there's a couple things around
the house that we'll we'll pay and she
does it and she's like Mommy owed me
three dollars and I'm like oh my gosh
okay like she's so diligent and then my
middle Caroline who's five is me as a
child or she's like I want to do nothing
but by but buy me everything you know so
uh teaching her to work and make money
but she will spend I mean if she has a
dollar she's like I'm ready to spend it
she does not want to hold on to money
she wants to spend it which was me as a
kid and so just already seeing them
again they're you know if they even
quote unquote make a mistake which
that's even crazy to say at it for a
little kid but it's so inexpensive it's
so not fatal like it is not a big deal
but letting them kind of learn these
things as early as possible is such a
gift and if you have older ones in the
house it's not too late like you can
still be talking to your kids or your
teenagers or even having them start to
work or mom and dad even put a set
amount of money every month in a
checking account and we had to budget
that money and we were not allowed to
ask them for anything like we couldn't
ask them for money at all and if we
needed more money than what was in our
account which we did they gave us like
barely anything I was like this is like
crazy uh we had to go work so we did we
worked through high school and made
money if we wanted to use it to go to
the mall or go to the movies so even if
you have teenagers and you haven't been
doing this you can still jump in and
start walking with them walking with
them when it comes to money and then the
last thing Christina's I want to hear
your thoughts too but one thing my
parents did and I really want to do this
with my kids even as they get older I
want to bring them into the struggle a
little bit like I don't want to scare
them but I do want to be like man
mom you know our minivan it's it's had
it's had its run I would love a new car
you know like when the minivans has its
run it doesn't it's three years old now
right now but I'm like down the road you
know yes and if we you know decide not
to buy it to be like yeah yeah I really
want a car but we're choosing not to
we're choosing to spend our money
somewhere else but like bring them into
those conversations of showing them what
do boundaries look like what do limits
look like and what does it look like to
say no even to us as adults like when we
say no I want you kids to know that we
are saying no to ourselves so that you
can learn how to do that because that's
that's a powerful principle with money
is learning to say no yes that's so good
a lot of adults have not learned about
principles but me too um okay so this
was kind of a personal question but I
feel like a lot of moms out there can
relate to this
we're in Target and our four-year-old is
having like level seven level ten
meltdown because they're not gonna get
the toy that they want and like I work
with money it's like we are not
excessive people but we still have those
moments where our kids lose their minds
when they say when we say no you can't
have that toy how should we handle that
um I mean I yeah I stick with no and now
I've learned to have the conversation
before we go in okay to the place
because especially like a Target because
they even just want to go like we'll
like walk the toy aisle so I'm like
torturing my own kids because I'm like
so we want to go see I'm like sure we
can walk but we are but like before we
get out of the car I'm like we're not
buying anything we're not yes and then
yeah I mean for me if they're throwing a
fit I don't personally want the public
shaming so I'm like I would probably
just leave I'm just like gather them up
like okay we're walking out we are
walking out that started to be our
conversation in the car I'm like we're
not buying anything and if you ask to
buy anything we are leaving and you
don't get to go to the store next time
that's right that's right and we love
the we love the store browsings yes see
my problem Christina right now as a
parent is I find this is where I get in
trouble is because if something
breaks or you know a toy messes or
something I got in the habit of being
like okay well let me look up on Amazon
on and it's like 8.99 like well we'll
get another one I did that for for a hot
second over and over and over again to
the point now my kids are like well just
Amazon it I'm like what we're exiting
that and I'm like no because we have to
pay for it and no we're not we're not
you have to take care of yourself so as
a mom I created that habit in our kids I
think it was during covid where I was
like it's you know we'll just figure it
out
um and so I had to back pedal on that
one because they learned that from me
and I thought oh no and I told them like
no this costs money and my Caroline was
like No just go on your phone mom to
Amazon and it just shows up and I was
like it's magic that costs money that
costs money and we don't have any and I
tell they think we're broke because I
just tell them all the time we don't
have the money for that we have to pay
for lights and food in the refrigerator
and we don't have any more money
but they don't know about our emergency
fund
well it's been funny we did no spin
January and I have a four-year-old and
he was impacted by it I'm like the fact
that he did not love no spin January I'm
like how do you even know how do you
know so parents your kids are aware have
these conversations we're having these
conversations and we're not perfect
that's right even though we do this
every day it is an ongoing process we'll
be right back give us a call Triple A
825-5225 this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show lots of
you started the year fired up to make
changes with your money but now that
some time has gone by you might be
starting to lose momentum you're not
alone change is hard and it's way harder
if you're trying to do it alone that's
why you've got to have people walking
with you and that's why a Financial
Peace University class has been a game
changer for millions of people in an FPU
class you'll learn our proven plan to
get out of debt and build wealth you'll
do it with other people going after the
same goals as you plus you'll have a
coordinator guiding you through the
whole thing it's a judgment-free place
to talk about money and get the
accountability you need it's people
leaning on people we need people that's
why this works you don't have to figure
this out alone there are hundreds of FPU
classes going on all across the country
both online and in person so go join one
right now to find an FPU class go to
ramsesolutions.com
FPU class all one word that's
ramseysolutions.com
FPU class all right let's go back to the
phones up next we have Michael calling
from Tyler Texas hey Michael welcome to
the show
hello uh I'm a college professor and I'm
single with no kids so I live on campus
in a private dorm room and that saves me
about eleven hundred dollars a month
nice so my co-worker my co-workers oh I
like where this is going all right my
co-worker who's a big Dave Ramsey fan he
says that I should move out because no
girl is ever going to want to date a guy
who lives
and has that been true for you so far
um I think my issue in that area is less
about my living situation and more about
I'm just kind of in a smaller town and
uh yeah there's a couple of
activity issues going on there but I've
never met anybody that said like well I
don't want to go out with you because
you know I don't think so Michael at
least not the kind of woman you would
want eventually like to marry right I
mean if you're living with your parents
yeah I could see someone being like hmm
okay so what are we doing there uh but
you're a professor at the school and so
your room and board is as if it's free
right for you you're not paying anything
well no it's it's just really really
cheap okay okay everything
no bills or anything yeah didn't alone
live on campus yeah he did with his fam
with with Sheila and I want to say one
more a baby a baby we're getting a baby
signal from the booth yeah still yeah Dr
John zalonia that's uh that's a host on
the show he him and his wife that's
right Sheila they they lived there and
he's like the coolest of the
personalities so like if you need
somebody with some swag you can be like
hey deloney did it deloni lived in a
dorm with with a wife and a kid no
Michael I don't I don't think so at all
I don't think that that's going to be a
major deterring I don't think it would
be for me I think again it's and it's
not because you don't you you lack uh
drive or willpower like those kind of
things could be a label on someone
that's still living at home that you're
like um why are you still living at home
uh but you're doing it for a reason
intentionally and it's yeah I don't that
doesn't so so did this friend who said
you're not going to be able to have any
game if you live in a dorm is he broke
um well he's married he's he's all right
he's doing all right
I feel like there's a good chance that
you might be taking advice from somebody
who's broke because he's a big Dave
Ramsey fan though right is he a Ramsey
Show fan the friends you said yeah I
mean he he doesn't have a bunch of
income but he's doing well for him so
he's doing all right for himself uh yeah
he's not broke bro so listen Michael
here's here's what I here's my I wish
the lonely was on the show to give you
relational advice here's my thing if it
becomes a pattern of women that you
really do a woman that you really like
and you guys have been dating and she's
like I can't date you anymore because
you live in the dorm and that happens
two three times then maybe there's a
pattern of okay maybe Christine and
Rachel were wrong maybe maybe that this
thing is is an issue but I just don't
think that's gonna happen and also also
like if you are on this plan and you
want to build wealth and your goal is to
be a baby steps millionaire I mean do
you really want to be with someone who
has a problem with you scrimping and
saving and doing what it's what you've
got to do to build wealth
here's a question for you Michael are do
you eventually want to be a homeowner
there like is that in your future to say
I would love to own a home because
owning a home is a great investment and
we do recommend people doing that when
the time is right for them financially
so is that that's a goal for you right
you don't want to live in a dorm your
whole life
but honestly I say now you might be
turning against me because here's my
position if if I get married yes but if
I just end up not being married then I
would not buy a house
if it's just me just single me I don't
even have any pets or anything I
wouldn't buy a house okay well
I would disagree a little bit I think
owning a home and having equity and all
of that I think is just a great asset to
your overall Financial picture uh but I
but for the day for the moment you're in
and for the dating advice that Christina
and I are going to give you I think
you're good I think you're fine yeah
well thanks for the call that is that is
a great question I hope I'm I hope I'm
right sorry Michael if I ruined your
love life like if if I'm wrong and
people won't take you because you're in
a dorm but I don't think that's gonna be
the case all right up next we have
Ashley calling from Houston Texas
hey Ashley welcome to the show
hi hi how can we help
hi so I have like I guess it's a real
estate question
um so my sister and I own a home
together
um it is paid off but I plan on
separating with her probably within the
next like two years
and I'm not really sure how to go about
it
okay give us a little back story how did
this come about
well we um I purchased a home when I was
18.
um it's paid off so it's not like we
have a note
um but I don't know like should I save
up the cash to to buy her out on her end
or should I take out a loan for it I
don't know is this a is this a
tumultuous relationship or is this like
a pretty clean version
yeah it's pretty clean it's just our
lifestyles are just becoming different
and I would just rather be alone
yeah and as and is her name attached to
the house legally
yeah both of our names are on there it
is on the house okay uh how much is that
how much is the home worth right now
about 350. okay
um and do you do you like the house do
you want to keep the house yeah we we've
we've uh agreed like I would keep the
house and then I would just pay
you know her have from the house yeah
okay so yeah I'm not sure how to go
about that how much do you
um how much do you make a year
uh from like 75 to like a hundred okay
and you're thinking it'll be another two
years
yeah I'm gonna I'm I gave myself to like
I was like I'll wait till I'm like 25
and then I'll be like okay well it's
time
how did you all pay off the house was
this from an inheritance or just
aggressively paying it down yeah
we got an inheritance when um I was 18.
okay
do you have any of that inheritance left
um I have about 40 000 in cash do you
have any other debt
um a little bit of credit card debt but
I'm paying that off okay how much is a
little
um it's like 12 000. oh okay
um
yeah I mean I mean Ashley there's a
couple things you guys can do I mean you
could you could sell it and you
take your half of the equity she takes
the other half and you start a clean
slate once you are debt free you have an
emergency fund I mean you want to be
financially ready to do that if that's
what you got I mean that would be that
would be clean to do it that way if not
yes you are going to have to buy her out
um at that point she would take on a
mortgage correct yeah but yes you would
have to you'd have to take the loan if
you didn't have the cash and so a part
of me is like okay would you go and buy
a
um you know
175 you know a hundred seventy five
thousand dollars home right now and take
a mortgage out would you go do that
right now
no okay I'm not entirely ready for that
yet
so and I don't know if you're gonna be
entirely ready for that in two years
either so those are the questions you
have to ask yourself is can I afford to
be able to do this and if you did you
know you'd want to do the math and make
sure that you know that loan is no more
than 25 of your take-home pay but I'm a
little nervous actually I kind of would
like you to just start clean uh by
selling it and you guys go your separate
ways yeah and I would sit down with a
real estate attorney to just make sure
that as you guys break this agreement
that's all your eyes are dotted tees are
crossed and everything is clean even
though it's family sometimes things can
get messy all right that puts this hour
of the Ramsay show and the books we'll
be back
foreign
hey it's Christina Ellis if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I'm Ramsay
personality Christina Ellis joined today
by my fellow Ramsey personality and
friend Rachel Cruz for taking your calls
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five give us a call let's chat first
up we've got Aaron calling from Tampa
Florida hey Aaron welcome to the show
hello how are you guys doing today we're
doing well how are you
just peachy well I'm calling because I
have a little bit of a dilemma in
regards to what I want to do for my
further education so if you have a
little bit of backstory I have two
Associates degrees and a professional
certification and aircraft and
maintenance which is as far as I know as
as far as I've determined so far my
dream career
and I in the process of getting this
degree my father got a benefit from the
V8 where I would be
afforded the opportunity to go to a
four-year degree a bachelor's degree
completely paid for
but what I'm coming into now is I've I'm
working part-time as a mechanic and I'm
loving the work
and I do my schoolwork and I my eyes
glaze over I have zero motivation I go
into work and I'm broad-eyed and
bushy-tailed and it feels like because
this opportunity is available and free
that I'm laundering it by not taking it
so I'm not sure if I should drop out and
continue on with the career do you need
the degree to do what you want to do
I do not uh I have I I have had these
certifications
to do what I want to do for about four
years now then
I would love to know Christina's house
I'm like then leave Erin drop out of
school you're fine you have the
qualifications of what you need to go
make money doing what you love and just
because something is free doesn't mean
that it's a good deal for you I mean you
know it's awesome that you had the
opportunity and I'm sure a lot of people
would love that but in your specific
situation you don't need it and so
there's no
there's no point unless it's furthering
your education for you to use a
certification later on in the same fee
you know you can keep going on with that
but if it's not what are you getting the
degree in
General business administration uh just
be just just for the heck of it you know
because it was give because the
opportunity came
actually yeah I figured it wouldn't hurt
if I go into the future and I have it
but at the same time I have no
motivation to continue uh I've been
working in a small business for six
years at this point yeah how much how
much school do you have left
two more years in the four year I
already again I have two Associates and
I could if I drop out I could go into a
job tomorrow making 35 an hour well you
are the example of why the four-year
degree is not everything we are all
about people getting an education so
that it can reach the career that they
want but you've already done that it's
not like you're somebody who doesn't
have an education and you can't reach
the the dream job you have two
Associates degrees you got your
certifications and you're working your
dream job and whenever you go back to
college let's say you do that four-year
degree there's still Roi on that and if
it's not going to you know increase your
your pay in your current job and your
dream field you also could be losing the
opportunity to spend more hours working
in the job that you love building more
credibility advancing your career and so
just I think there's a little bit of
that feeling of it's what I should do
right it's what America says is the path
that you have to go to be successful you
have to get a four-year degree you have
to do that and that's just that's not
true and especially since it's free that
pressure feels like oh gosh then I
there's no option I I have to take this
because it's free and it feels like yeah
that you that you have to for some
reason right with the pressure Christina
was saying so do you do you have outside
pressure like you said it was through
your dad does he is he kind of pushing
that narrative that you need to go back
to school
she was for a while I talked to him
about it yesterday and he said he'd
support me either way I go and at my
significant other feels the same way
she's she said do your dream you don't
you don't act the same on the days you
do go to school versus the days you work
the days I go to school I'm I'm just
bitter and negative and it's just not a
good not a good time for me so yeah and
I wouldn't base this decision off of
your emotions in the moment because it's
short it's it's a you know it's a fairly
short amount of time right so if you
even if you had to grind it out for two
years and you were miserable in those
days you'd get through it and then you'd
have your degree and you could keep
going but the reason it's not I'm I'm
saying this not because you're not happy
on days that you're going to school but
because you just don't need it Aaron
like you just don't you don't need it so
I would I would drop out and and thank
your dad be gracious be grateful because
of his service so they tell him thank
you for his service from us because of
his service you know you were given that
opportunity and that you're grateful for
it but but the course of your life Aaron
yeah you don't you don't need it so and
what's so interesting I posted something
the other day about student loans on
Instagram and I had several comments
from people where they were like I went
into so much debt and I'm not even using
my degree and yet I have friends who
didn't go to college in a four-year
school and they're making six figures
they're doing amazing and they have zero
student loan debt so we really have to
Buck up against this idea that everyone
has to get a four-year degree that
everyone needs to go to school that it
is the ticket that it is the key that's
going to make you successful because
that's not that's just not true we love
education I love obviously I help people
go to school debt free I built my career
on that but I'm still not going to say
that it's for everyone we need mechanics
we need people who are in the trades who
are working hard and who like we
literally depend on every day and so I
think you are such a great example Aaron
of somebody who who doesn't necessarily
need a four-year degree
I think actually that could potentially
be kind of a waste of time and
potentially not Roi
that's the that's the feeling that I
have been feeling as well that has I
could be making more money and getting
the experience needed to further my
career it was just hard for me to
rationalize that oh it's only two more
years oh I'll have it in the end I can
do if something happens and I could do
something else but it's I can't really
see myself using the degree in in the
future
well it's a good question and I think
that it's wise for you to work all the
way through it because for some people
like you said Rachel there are
situations where people just aren't
motivated schools sometimes can be not
fun and ultimately in the long run they
need to push through in order to get to
that dream career there are situations
where it's just it's just not going to
be fun you have to go to class maybe
chemistry or trigonometry it's not going
to be the most exciting thing but it's a
means to an end so for sure if you are
looking into a career where you need
that degree and you feel grumpy when you
go to class you may just need to push
through it like that's just you know
I've had classes in college that I
didn't enjoy that I went to anyways
however that does not mean that's true
for everyone I love this question stop
in the moment and go hey is this
necessary is a degree necessary for all
of you who are about to go to college or
especially for people who are thinking
about grad school it's really important
to sit down and look at the numbers look
at the long-term Roi is this degree
worth it is it going to pay off it could
be yes but don't just blindly go just
because you feel like it's the right
Next Step that you quote unquote should
do
give us a call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'll be right
back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show we are
all feeling the strain of inflation
these days but I want you to know you
can still have Financial Peace even when
the prices of groceries are rising
through the roof that's why I'm going on
the Building Wealth Tour live with Dave
and our team of personalities join us as
we share the proven plan for your money
so you can build wealth and have peace
no matter what's going on in the economy
on February 16th we'll be in
Indianapolis with Dave Ramsey George
camel and Jade warshaw next the tour is
heading to Austin on February 23rd with
Dave Ramsey Ken Coleman John deloney and
Jade warshaw on April 24th catch me Dave
Ramsey George Campbell in Salt Lake City
and our final stop of the tour is in
Anaheim on May 2nd with Dave Ken deloney
and me tickets start at 49 or you can
get a pack of four tickets starting at a
hundred and seventy five dollars go to
ramseysolutions.com events to reserve
your seats now and Jay or um and I'll be
in Indianapolis I'm like where am I I
locked you off and Salt Lake City I'll
be there yes I know I forgot all Rachel
Cruz is gonna be it's gonna be on the
road too
these are really fun events though they
really are Dave does a great Keynotes at
the beginning really showing the
landscape of what Building Wealth looks
like over time and even taking his
learning from history of like okay what
works what doesn't work and then we all
get to sit kind of panel style and talk
about current events like what is going
on in the world how do you build wealth
literally in 2023 with everything going
on and so it is it's a really it's a
it's a really fun event it's kind of a
different format than what we usually do
but we've done it I guess for two
seasons now on the road so uh yeah
that's gonna be great it's so important
too because we're coming out of this
season where crypto is huge and all
these different investment schemes and
ideas and Tick Tock hacks were big and
now we have inflation and a lot of fear
so to be able to come to cities and
Speak Life and truth and hope is just
really powerful yeah that's a great
point because I'm like you know you
think about this time last year when we
were in the spring it was it was crypto
the housing market people were freaked
out about you know we thought it was me
a big you know people thought it was
gonna be a bubble and then you fast
forward 12 months and it's a totally
different set of issues eggs it's all
chickens how quick things change it's
pretty wild so yeah so we're gonna come
join us we're ready to chat with you all
have that conversation all right let's
go back to the phones next up we have
Matthew calling from Bowling Green
Kentucky hey Matthew welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for having me hey thanks
for being here how can we help
thanks I just want you guys know that I
am 19 years old I am graduating
undergrad in May uh completely debt free
and I had some questions uh about what
I'm gonna do after that
um so I've been accepted to medical
school
um and that's looking like it's going to
be about a 250 000 Adventure all in
right
um
I do have some savings um it's not
really in that ballpark um I've applied
to a lot of scholarships
um but that will at most cover about 100
Grand of that Adventure
um so my parents have offered to help
and they've given me a couple different
ways that they uh that they've offered
to help me and I'm just wondering which
of these would be best for me
um and kind of my future Financial self
okay let's let's walk through it
all righty first um they told me that
they would be able to pay for my rent
throughout the whole time there so
that'd be about 11 or 1200 a month or
they could take out a mortgage
um and they could
um maybe uh I would have to cash out all
my savings
um but they would be willing to pay for
everything else
um pay the mortgage that they can afford
independently
um and then after I'm out of medical
school we could sell that house and
instead of having paid that money in
rent I would have uh built equity in a
house and I can apply that money uh to
what will be my student loans there
okay this mortgage would that be on
their primary house
uh yes it would um they are just about
ready to pay off their house uh actually
um and it's something that they can't
afford to send the names of the
guidelines
I don't know that we'd ever really
recommend taking out a mortgage to pay
for college so that's that wouldn't be
in the Ramsay guidelines and I'd also
would say they can't really afford that
we want them to pay off their house and
build wealth for their sake
um and college for parents is paying for
college that's that's optional so first
we're going to want to protect the
retirement if they have to take a
mortgage to pay for college they can't
they can't afford it
okay
um so tell us yeah so you're 19 and you
just graduate you're about to graduate
from undergrad
yes that's amazing I did a shift uh so
far um and just kind of going through on
the borrowed future plan there
um and looking and seeing uh just all
that stuff has been really inspiring I'm
doing everything I can to sort of
eliminate as much debt from my future
life as I can yeah how did you go to
undergrad debt free
uh so actually there was a program here
um and I was able to get through two
years early
um uh I had really high ACT scores uh as
a as a sophomore in high school
um and so they paid for my first two
years of college
um because I chose to stay in state
um they told me they'd pay for the rest
of it as well your parents would
uh no uh the actual school I got I got a
full ride scholarship that's great
Matthew that's wonderful okay so medical
school's coming up and if I wrote down
it correctly you had you you have a
hundred thousand dollars towards it
correct
with scholarships they're about okay and
so that means you you would have a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars left
to to pay
for school correct because it's 250 000
total and you mentioned some savings how
much is the savings
uh so the savings actually uh would be
part of that 150 000 that I have
um there so I've got thirty thousand
dollars in savings
um a forty thousand dollar savings
rather and about
um
a potential for about a hundred thousand
dollars in scholarships um but that's
still up in the air as of right now
that's wonderful I just want to stop for
a second and say good job like the fact
that you already have that savings the
fact that you already have scholarships
lined up you're you're killing it so far
so thank you
um I I also want to highlight like you
sound brilliant like the fact that
you've already done all this you're
graduating at 19. I love that you have a
hundred thousand dollars in scholarships
but why stop there
you know yeah it was medical school
there are a lot of ways we can get that
paid for I've seen a lot of URLs
guidance on MD PHD programs
um and like uh some stuff with the Army
um both of those programs both the ndphd
actually isn't offered at my school
right
um and so that's something that's not on
the table for me
um and uh I'd really like to be able to
stay in Kentucky with my family and so
that's not really something that I can
do uh with the Army Route
um so yeah I would challenge that
Matthew Matthew I'll I'll challenge that
though because if you had a program that
would pay for you to go to medical
school in Indiana
would you not take that just to be near
your family
um
perhaps but but it's not a decision that
like at 19 years old I'm not ready to
sign the next seven years of my life
after Medical School away you know so
after four years medical school they
require seven years of service
um where they can move me here there
yonder well we're even talking about the
MD PhD not not military I was talking
about the other program
oh um no I've actually already been
accepted to one program
um and that was part of the the
conditional for acceptance was
um that I could only apply to their
program
um and they had some of the best tuition
rates out there and plus I've done some
stuff that's very similar to indeed PhD
some research stuff like that and it's
really not my alley there so um so was
it an early decision program where you
signed like a binding agreement saying
you wouldn't apply somewhere else or
what what did that look like
yes pretty much you know that was it
and with that you kind of made the
commitment on the front end that you
would go to that school no matter what
the finances looked like
uh yes that's correct
okay so with this scholarship allocation
is that like a certain amount each year
or is that like you have a hundred
thousand dollars to spend you know
paying for each year as you go
that would be a certain amount each year
um and it would only be applicable to
the tuition part of it I believe so how
much do you have left to make up for the
first year
for the first year
um
probably uh about
uh with my savings about thirty thousand
dollars and it would probably take me
about about zero savings about zero
savings
okay
so then I I'm if I'm in your shoes and
I've made that commitment then I am
applying to scholarships like crazy you
did say your parents can help out some
if they can help out without taking a
mortgage out that's great but at this
point with the fact that you've
committed you got to just hustle and
figure out how to find that money if
it's not a binding commitment then I
would encourage you to look at other
programs because you are brilliant and
you have the chance of getting a full
ride somewhere else we'll be right back
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trustee
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five today's
question of the day comes from Ashley in
Boston I'm a 21 year old full-time
student and will graduate at the end of
this year I have about 18 000 in debt on
a car and I have twenty thousand dollars
in savings ooh I do not have any other
kind of debt I also have a credit card
that I use to get access to online
textbooks and these sites only accept
credit cards I want to do the baby steps
but should I wait until I graduate to
get rid of my car loan and credit card
that's a great question Ashley um
you know right now since you have one
more year left of school I would say
hold tight and just keep saving money
and make sure you get through college
debt free
um because I don't think you have any
student loans is what you claim so you
say I have no other debt student loans
are debt for those of you that might be
confused so yeah so hopefully actually
you don't have that so I would say to
just to stay put get through school make
sure that you graduate debt free and
then once you graduate and you kind of
make that transition to where you're
going to be then I would plug in your
savings which will be more than eighteen
thousand at that point hopefully and I'm
sorry more than twenty thousand and I
would automatically pay off the car but
I don't think I would drain my savings
account down yeah to two thousand
dollars as a college student because
your number one goal right now is to get
through school debt free yeah we want to
yeah and there's just unexpected
expenses that can come up in college I
want to challenge the notion that I have
to have a credit card to get online
textbooks and that the sites only accept
credit cards I think that's kind of a
common misperception a lot of sites will
say like enter your credit edit card
here but they typically still accept
debit cards right like they still accept
that so
um I don't want anybody to hear that and
think oh I have to have a credit card
I'll be limited if I don't have one I
have not found that in my experience and
I own zero no yeah and it's usually you
know with the processing and stuff for
the most part I mean obviously if you
hit debit you got to put in a PIN number
if you're there at the checkout but I
even run my debit card as a credit
because I want it to run through Visa or
Mastercard whatever the you know
whatever the emblem is on my debit card
to make sure that I have full protection
as if it's a credit card transaction
even though the money's coming right out
of my checking account because it's a
debit card so yeah people get a little
bit confused on that but I if it accepts
a credit card it will accept a debit
card yes there you go do you ever catch
yourself at the store whenever the clerk
is like credit card and I'm like damn it
just so people know I'm using my debit
card
but I do love that you're in college and
you're thinking about the baby steps uh
just be intentional with that you know
keep that savings we're definitely not
saying you know go spend it and don't
care about it but like Rachel said keep
building it because hopefully when you
graduate you'll not only be able to pay
off that car straight away but you'll
also be able to have your fully funded
emergency fund and when you get your
first job immediately start investing
that would be the goal all right let's
go back to the phones next up we have
Andy calling from Dayton Ohio hey Andy
welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me thanks for
calling so my wife my wife and I are
about to have our second kid and we're
looking forward congratulations
oh thank you and it's her birthday today
happy birthday honey happy birthday
we're looking forward to having a third
kid shortly after so the question is
kind of centered around in about two
years from now we're looking to kind of
move into our forever home so my
question is I've got about 38 000 left
in student loans but I also have about
250 000 in my 401k
so
um the the variable interest rate just
went up to like 8.8 percent or something
crazy high on the student loans
um but given the fact that I'll have a
really good pension and my 401k is on
Pace to be around 2 million when I
retire is it completely frowned upon to
maybe borrow 30k against the 401K to pay
off the student loans so then when we're
looking to move into our house in a
couple years we'll be completely debt
free and that 401k will be paid back
yeah no I would not borrow against my
401k I would not how much do you make a
year
120 okay okay pay off your student loan
you guys could take 18 months and pay
this off
18 months you could pay that you're 14
12 months you guys could pay this off
yeah well you know we're growing our
family we've got other expenses you know
we're just in a new house now
um
and we're just trying to think about how
to free up some liquid in a couple years
from now when we move in 2004 okay I
don't want you to move into your forever
home with debts do you have any do you
have any savings besides retirement
uh we've got about 18 000 right now okay
so here's here's what I would do Andy
since you called the Ramsay show we're
gonna give you the Ramsay advice uh and
I would throw
seventeen thousand dollars there at your
student loan and then you got 21
000 left on it pay it off this year Andy
and then you guys save up get a big
emergency fund then save up for a down
payment and then move into your dream
home where you're not you're not broke
you know you you don't have debt you
have cash in the bank you're not
borrowing from your 401k and you have
the ability then to really step into
your home and be like okay yeah we we
have this like very very solid Financial
Foundation under us in order to do that
and so I think the the problem
especially with student loans and
Christina you can probably speak on this
is it's so
it's a bigger debt usually from people
and it's so normalized that it kind of
can become a little bit apathetic of
like uh I don't know it's just here and
this is what it is and it's not this
like intense like get this thing out of
my life yeah well I mean cultures told
us that it's normal culture tries to
make it seem like it's what everybody
takes out for college and that you're
gonna have it for the next 15 to 20
years and that does not have to be true
we see it every day here at Ramsay
people tackling the student loan debt
and not carrying it around like a puppy
for the next 15 years like you can get
rid of these student loans and Annie I
know you want to do it but
um you're talking about your 401k and
you're talking about the 250 and how
it'll be 2 million in retirement but the
problem is when you start pulling from
your 401k it's kind of a slippery slope
right like it's easy to go okay we'll
just pull from it it's gonna be fine and
we'll pay off the student loans and then
you know you have another baby and
things are they're more expensive here
and then all these things can start
pulling popping up and then you're not
on track to two million dollars in
retirement and and it's just getting
kind of messy so we would definitely not
recommend pulling pulling from them and
if you leave your job you have to pay it
immediately but I mean like there's just
there's a lot of risk there involved and
so I would not yeah I would not touch
her 401K Andy I would cash flow that's
because you guys have the money you're
able to do it you have a great income
you have savings and so it's just it
from the Ramsay baby steps you're just
it feels like you're doing things a
little bit out of order right and so I
just want to get you back to that clear
path because we have found
with this plan I mean we can't argue it
because literally millions of people
have done it and they have done the
steps and it is the quickest way from
point A to point B to not only get
control of your money but to build
wealth long term and so keeping this
debt around is stopping you from that
and so I would I would throw everything
at the debt that you have now except for
a thousand dollars you guys aggressively
pay it off and then
um well you guys are expecting Andy you
said that right I'm sorry you you guys
are about to have a baby
yes next month okay next one okay I'm
sorry let me let me backtrack just a
second I would pause wait wait a month
make sure baby and mom come home and
everything and then once they're back
everything is good everyone's healthy
then that's when I would start paying
off the student loan debt with your
savings you guys attack it and then save
open emergency funds of three to six
months of expenses a down payment on the
dream home and I would I would keep
going and I promise what this also does
what this also does again is when you
don't owe anyone anything not only
mathematically financially does it get
you ahead faster
but you sleep at night the amount of
anxiety that you just don't have when
you have Savings in the bank you don't
have any payments you're not trying to
borrow from this thing to that thing it
is clean and there is something about
our level of anxiety that we carry
around as we're kind of you know going
through the motions of money and the way
that the world works
and I'm telling you if you do something
that is so not is so weird which is what
I'm telling you to do I know
mathematically you're like that doesn't
really make sense
until you're going to get a different
result than what the world has and it's
peace Financial Peace and that's what we
want for you so uh hang on the line Andy
I'm gonna have Emily pick up because I
want you and your wife to go through
Financial Peace University while you got
a newborn with you guys and you're not
sleeping at nights turn us on and go
through this class though because for
real getting the basics of this is
really really important and follow it
and just follow it because it works yeah
and it may not be easy it may be a
season of sacrifice but remember it's
just a season you will get through it
we'll be right back this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsey personality Christina Ellis
joined today by my co-host and friend
Rachel Cruz we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five next up we have Jason calling from
Boise Idaho hey Jason welcome to the
show
hey Christina and Rachel how are you
guys doing we're doing well how can we
help
well real quick I just want to say I
appreciate um Ramsey Ramsey used to be a
four-letter word in our house and now
it's almost the term of endearment if
that makes any sense I'm glad it changed
I'm glad it changed it has my wife and I
have been we've been budgeting we've
been doing really good and we just in
the last year
um we have really gotten intense and
started
um getting kicked off at debt
um they paid off her car just a couple
months ago and yeah snowball we're still
on the next debt but here's the dilemma
and the question
um my wife is a realtor and she just
sold her first house
um this just a few weeks ago
and with the economy and inflation and
everything
um her and I were talking about you know
where's that money going and of course I
want to pay off the credit card it would
completely make it go away
um and she wants to possibly beef up the
emergency fund for just in case and I
just want your guys's thoughts on that
okay so share some numbers with us Jason
what how much will she be bringing home
from her commission and congrats to her
on the first house that's exciting
close to 12 000. nice and how much is
the credit card
um well the the next one is about seven
seven thousand okay and what
does have
we have a couple more credit cards I
mean in total we got about what are they
separately so you have a 7000 a
um a 9 000 and a ten thousand okay and
any other debt or it's just these credit
cards
and my uh my chart payment my truck um
how much is it paid off eventually I owe
7 000 on that seven thousand okay
um and she and and you you guys have
this the thousand dollar emergency fund
yes okay
um
let me say this Jason I understand where
she's coming from and just so you hear
from a from a woman's perspective
one of the greatest the number one
Financial fear among women is financial
insecurity it's like that that feeling
of it exactly what she said if something
happens are we going to be okay and so
how much do you bring in I know she's
she's selling houses what do you bring
in a month
um about 30 3 800 a month okay
so
here's where I if you were if yes I'm
putting myself in your wife's shoes
because I understand even though I teach
this and we talk about baby step one
which we're gonna get to that in a
second where her fear is coming from is
very real and very true but also it can
be magnified because of the what we're
hearing from the news from Facebook from
family from friends about how the entire
economy is going to collapse and we're
uh we're all screwed and oh my gosh
what's gonna happen you know that
feeling and then you go to the grocery
store and you're like crap I'm paying so
much for eggs and like you know things
are more expensive so all of that it
comes into play so what I would do is
sit down with her and just say hey
here's the plan that we're working and
if something were to happen which this
is what we teach you pause the debt
snowball and you beef back up the
emergency fund for the thing that
happens right if there's
um a roof that leaks or there's a
medical something happens you pause the
debt snowball continue to pay my own
payments and then you fix the emergency
of where it's at so so so it's not like
you guys are gonna you know
go under or something you're able to
pause and be able to beef up that
emergency fund if needed to pay for the
emergency so that always kind of gives
me
comfort knowing okay if something were
to happen we're not going to continue to
to pay on this debt while the roof is
falling in or so you know I mean
whatever the the scary thing is
um so that's helpful and then a little
bit of that fear of like oh no it's only
a thousand dollars let's get out of debt
so much faster it's a little bit of that
motivator to push through and pay it off
that much faster yeah that's that's part
of it it's supposed to be uncomfortable
for this season like that's that's just
part of it you want to get rid of it
you're the gazelle running from the
cheetah like it's it's scary and
honestly I have
um I I sort of I'm in property
management and last summer I bought a
pressure washers to to go out and
pressure wash houses I mean I'm hustling
you know 60 70 hours a week in the
summertime
um just so I can continue kicking Beth's
butt so I can always work harder and
still pass that without you know using
that eleven thousand dollars and just
putting it in a cushion I don't I don't
want to do that no yeah and I and I
wouldn't because you guys are gonna be
able to knock I mean you're gonna pay
off your truck I mean like there's
things things that you you guys can do
with this money that again is efficient
and getting you guys that much closer to
being debt free so have you guys gone
through Financial Peace University
together
we we did um through our church I even
helped facilitate it second year
um but for the longest time we were just
learning budgeting and learning to to
operate you know our our our budget and
just in the last year we finally started
getting intense and dmad
have you all kind of mapped out how long
it's going to take to pay off this debt
like what is your projected payoff date
we haven't honestly no we haven't messed
it out like that I would encourage you
to do that because I think I think for
your wife especially with the the
concerns and the fear around not having
an emergency fund that is real but
hopefully seeing a Finish Line that can
really help you drive harder and faster
it's like we can say the why but if it
feels like you know this season May last
forever we don't know when it's going to
end that can feel really hard but to see
you know a definitive point where it's
like this is going to be paid off in you
know a year or 18. yeah Jason if she
sells two more houses you guys are debt
free at the same this is what I'm saying
so like you're you're so y'all are close
you're gonna you're gonna get there
you're gonna get there yeah okay keep it
up you're doing it you're doing a great
job just stay the course I know this is
the time where it can be intimidating
yeah and it can be scary and I would
encourage her too to
to um you guys are budgeting together
which I'm thankful for and to focus on
what's going on in your household
because again a lot of this fear that
we're seeing out there
um some of it is very real that's you
know pertaining to your household but
sometimes it is just so magnified in our
heads because it feels like everyone
else is freaking out so I should be the
one freaking out too right so you wanna
you wanna calm that fear down with a lot
of facts as well and that's what
Christina was saying even mapping out
your debt snowball and seeing it
visually is so helpful to be like okay
okay if this isn't forever we're not
saying that I have a thousand dollars in
the bank for the rest of your life no no
no you're gonna be bulking that up soon
but all of that intensity and all that
Focus to get this debt out of your life
changes the game yeah and it's good it
sounds like you guys are pretty close to
the same page but there is that little
bit of tension and she wants it too but
Rachel what would you say there's so
many people I feel like that call who
their spouse is like totally on a
different page maybe their spouse is
like no kryptos the next thing or are
like Ramsay's still a four-letter word
in their house what would you say to
that that husband or wife who's trying
to speak to the other and and get them
to kind of come over a bit Yeah well you
know money is usually never about money
I mean like a lot of the stuff and so
there's issues underneath that that I
would want to get at and so you know for
some of you that have been listening and
you're huge fans of the show and you're
so hardcore sometimes you're the problem
and you go to your spells and you're
like oh my gosh we have to do this we
have to do this we have to do this we
and if your response is like whoa whoa
you're like you're not on board you know
I mean sometimes it's like the
legalistic person is the one that you're
like you you need to chill and actually
like have a relational bone in your body
to relate to your spouse so sometimes
it's this feeling of like you're trying
to control me and the spouse feels
controlled so what's your approach you
know what you know how are you doing
that and then the opposite is true right
there can be we've heard this a lot the
spouse that's just like no I deserve to
spend what I want to spend I don't want
to be accountable to anyone and that's a
level of immaturity and that immaturity
is going to show in other parts of your
marriage in your life not just your
money and that's the problem we want to
get at right so like there's yes usually
underneath that there's there's some
there's some underlying things whether
it's fear
immaturity control issues like whatever
the thing is getting underneath that
layer to say okay because what we teach
is not well it is crazy in the world it
is not normal but also when you look at
it it's like live on less than you make
if you don't have the money don't buy it
like it's really not that crazy right I
mean it really is just common sense and
so uh I think that's part of it too is
is plugging your ears on all this get
rich quick stuff all this thing that
feels easy because common sense and
actually doing the work and persevering
is hard it is hard work but you get the
results
that's so good that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show and the books we'll be
back soon
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Ramsay personality
Christina Ellis joined today by fellow
Ramsey personality Rachel Cruz for
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five and hey if
you like the show please consider
subscribing leaving a review and sharing
it with a friend we want to continue to
reach people and help them build wealth
and win with their money alright let's
go to the phones first up we have Nicole
calling from Jackson Mississippi hey
Nicole Welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call hey thanks
for calling um I am calling about uh
potentially
um pursuing a doctorate degree I'm not
really sure if I can afford it and if I
can I'm not really sure the best way to
pay for it um obviously alone is um out
of the question so I have some options
and I'm just not sure that it's the the
best thing for me to do okay so what
would you be what would you be studying
okay and and what are you doing right
now
um I am in the kind of corporate
training world and that's where I would
like to stay so the degree would be in
instructional design and and what will
this degree do for your career I feel
like there's a lot of hesitation in your
voice you said you're not sure if it's
the right decision yeah
um there's no guarantee that
um that this degree will do all that
much as far as you know future earning
potential and and that kind of thing
it's more just something that I've kind
of always wanted to do
um just sort of for myself whether it
um pays off financially or not that's
that's the hesitation there's not an
employer that's saying you know if you
get this degree then oh you're going to
get this huge raise or anything like
that what is it going to do for you
Nicole when you say I want to do this
for me
what is it what is that giving you
um it would just be a personal
accomplishment something that I could
you know that I could just look at at
some point and say oh look at this this
thing so I'm going to ask you again so
what does that so you have the degree on
the wall what is what is that what does
that do to Nicole what does that do
um it's something to be proud of it's
hard it's hard work so I think it's
something and there's a lot of other
hard work out there to be proud of too
right right that's true so I'm just
trying to I'm trying I'm trying to dig a
little bit deeper into your why and what
that and what that motivation is right
like is that is there a there's a
there's there's something under there
that's causing you and I don't know if
that's what you've heard in the past
from someone that you think that like
this
you know that this is important I don't
know if it's from someone in your past I
don't know if this is um you feel like
if I have this somehow I'm going to be
more complete I don't know I don't know
what it is for you but usually what we
find that if it doesn't have a financial
benefit right if that's a financial
benefit this would probably be a
different discussion that we'd walk
through options but if it's just for
Nicole I think you can find that
satisfaction other places that doesn't
require going and getting a doctorate
for something that you don't need in
life
right and that's one of the reasons why
I think that you know paying for it has
kind of become a sticking point is that
you know it is going to be expensive
um and I don't mind to you know save
money or whatever it is that I have to
do to pay for it um but I think that
probably is part of the hesitation is
just is this really the right thing to
do and then if it is how do I map it out
and make sure that it's the most well
Nicole what does the rest of your
financial situation look like do you
have any debt right now
now I have no debt whatsoever I'm in my
home
um my salary before tax is about 68 000
and I have about
um about 125 000 in retirement accounts
and mutual funds and emergency funds and
that type of thing and how old are you
41.
and how much is how much will the
doctorate be if you just went and did it
um with the program that I'm looking at
with the um financial assistance that
I'm likely to qualify for it's probably
cost
um a total of about between 40 and 50
000. okay and how much is it per year
uh per year it would probably be twelve
thousand okay and is this an online
program or in person
uh it's a hybrid program
okay mostly online some in person
are you set on this specific school are
you open to other options no I'm
definitely open to other options okay so
hearing all of this and hearing you know
the doctor it's a personal a personal
accomplishment that you're excited about
I'm kind of wondering like how would you
feel about slowing it down maybe going
with an online degree program because a
lot of times those can be a lot cheaper
and a lot more flexible where maybe you
do it over the course of six or eight
years in cash flow it
well that was going to be one of my
questions is it better to do it more
slowly and just cash flow it as I can I
do have some things I can sell
um that could potentially be enough to
pay for it over a shorter period of time
but I don't know if that's necessarily
the best way to go either well I mean if
there's not like a specific timeline and
you're in a program that's pretty
flexible where they're not like it's not
a cohort program where you have to go
with a certain group and take 15 hours
every semester if it's an online program
where you just need to finish 60 credits
over the course of however long it takes
then that would be up to you like if you
want to go a little bit faster than
maybe you sell those things so you can
pay for the next class a little bit
quicker and if you don't then you don't
yeah that's actually a really good point
I hadn't really thought of it in those
terms
um but maybe taking longer since there
isn't a hurry to get it finished maybe
that would be yeah a pretty good option
to consider is just what's the how long
will they let me stretch it out for yeah
yeah really I really do like being in
school I mean if it's free I would go
forever I never thought good for you
Nicole it's not free
I love that you're admitting that too
that you're like hey there may not be an
Roi I just like it yeah I do I like
writing papers and that's great you know
some people like taking vacations with
their money some people want to go and
get a dog protocol so I think that's
awesome but uh but let me just say
before we hang up no debt do not take
retire do not take retirement out do not
be cashing out your 401K or what they're
ready to pay for it do not go and get it
put a mortgage on your house like like
nothing like that this is going to be
cash flowing this is extra money Nicole
has because this is what she wants to
spend her money on and do it and that
and that's awesome that's great if that
if you have the cash for it and this is
what you want to do then that's that's
the thing about money is it's a tool to
create a life that you love and if this
is the life you love Nicole
you go for it
I guess I could just write papers in my
free time if I wanted well also Nicole
okay one more just bonus bonus thought
bonus tip is I mean maybe you even
consider a second career like if you
love papers if you love education that
much maybe you go work at a university
and then a lot of times when you work at
a university you can get a tuition
discount of like 80 90
oh that's a good point that is a very
good point when you were in today
Christina yes I'm glad you called this
was my favorite thing to talk about I
was like don't go to school Nicole you
don't need it
I just so appreciate the honest dude I'm
impressed it's great it's great we're
taking your calls at AAA
825-5225 we'll be right back this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go back
to the phones next up we have Lorraine
calling from Nashville Tennessee hey
Lorraine welcome to the show
hey what's up guys thanks for taking my
call hey thanks for calling how can we
help
yeah so um my husband and I we actually
live in Washington state we're
relocating to Nashville this summer and
kind of what I wanted to get y'all's
input on is what do you think is the
best way to go about trying to buy a
house as a first-time homebuyer when
we're relocating and a lot of these
mortgage companies that we've reached
out to and banks are requiring job
security in order to get a mortgage in
that in that state in Tennessee and then
we at least for me my husband's job is
able to transfer my job's not
um not
um
available for me to work at in Tennessee
so I can't get job security and then so
we can't I can't get a job without a
home and then I can't get a home without
a job yeah totally I just gotta like
stuck in a tickle do you guys know like
um yes types of mortgages that are best
for like first-time home buyers well I
would say number one yeah you're picking
the best city in America coming to
Nashville so I'm so glad you're going to
be neighbors with us it's a great City
uh but for anyone that's relocating I
would always recommend renting for a
year just rent for a year uh because
you're going to be able to quickly see
all the different parts of the city
right I mean like even Nashville it's
not a major major city but there's
enough difference depending on which
suburb if you go north south east west
like you're gonna start to feel out okay
this is what the city's like and and and
I I don't know I always like not being
tied down to a house especially if it's
somewhere you haven't lived before uh so
I would recommend you guys guys rent for
a year and then you'll probably find a
job you'll have some you know you'll
have that that job security going in to
get a mortgage are you guys in a place
to buy a house do you have debt do you
have a down payment what do you guys
have
well we're completely debt free we've
been a missionary for the past four
years so we've been moving off support
and so once we stepped out of ministry
we we're now working full-time here in
Washington I'm actually born and raised
in Nashville so we're moving down there
so I can be close to my family okay
knowing the area it's not yeah it's very
familiar to me you know I'm looking at
Columbia Spring Hill you know more South
Nashville gotcha
um so living off support has definitely
kind of been a hardship and a sense of
trying to save a bunch of money yeah and
then out here in Washington where we
live I mean we it's hard trying to save
when our rents almost half of our income
and just because that's just how it is
out here everything's super expensive so
trying to save
um has been challenging you know we so
do you guys in Financial Peace we got
our budget and everything like that did
you guys have an emergency do you have
an emergency fund
yes we have our thousand dollar
emergency fund
um my in-laws gave us a gift for a down
payment but once we stepped out of
ministry we had to take some of that out
for me to buy a car
um but we just both of us bought our
cars just flat out in cash so we don't
have any car payments
yeah yeah it's great the Ramsey steps
with going to school so we're paying for
schools to go so awesome in that sense
yeah just trying to save and everything
has just been challenging yeah here on
the on the show people my age like oh
yeah I have a hundred thousand dollars
in savings it's like what I know I know
totally okay so you have you have your
thousand dollars you have no debt you so
you do not have your fully funded
emergency fund yet
well I mean if I thought the thousand
dollars was the emergency fund I mean
that's just what we kind of been keeping
for a rainy day okay so that that's
maybe stuff yeah yep so that's baby step
one is that thousand dollar that's your
starter emergency fund then you're gonna
go and pay off all of your debt which
you guys don't have any debt so you get
to move on to baby step three which is
saving three to six months of expenses
which is your fully funded emergency
fund so you can add to that thousand
dollars let that be your springboard and
you guys start saving up a big rainy day
fund of three to six months of expenses
and then baby step three B is saving up
for a down payment because you guys
don't even have money for a down payment
right now right
we have about six grand right now okay
just because we're trying to pay off
that gift that his parents gave us
um that we had to use for my car Wait
the gift and then with the gift it's a
gift or is it a loan
no they gifted it to us so why are you
paying it back
no no we're not paying it back to them
we're paying it back to ourselves like
they gave us ten thousand to use for a
down payment my husband and I since I
needed a car we took five grand of that
to buy myself a car and so now we're
just trying to build that 10 brand back
up but it's still a gift it's still ours
okay I hear you okay so yeah so I would
um
I would use that for my emergency fund I
would not use that for my down payment
because you guys aren't in that place
yet you guys need some cash in the bank
for an emergency fund and then so that
10 grand that they gifted you
um is so kind and so great but that's
gonna be allotted to an emergency fund
instead of a down payment right now and
then you guys save up a down payment on
a house because what happens is you move
you buy a house you don't put a lot down
and you have no cash in the bank and
suddenly the roof starts leaking you
notice that the insulation is bad I mean
stuff starts breaking and you don't have
the money
to go and fix these things because home
ownership is expensive and so having
that big emergency fund is really
important before buying a home because
the most stressful thing that you can do
is go buy a home
and have no money and stuff starts
breaking and then all of a sudden you're
like oh my gosh I'm stressed and this
house suddenly has become a burden not a
blessing that I thought so I would
really really recommend you guys save up
that big emergency funds save up a down
payment of 10 to 20 percent down and
then you guys buy a home so again Lauren
I mean I would and I would and I would
still recommend renting I mean even
though you know the area which is great
yeah I just don't think you guys are
going to be in a financial position this
summer in six months maybe you will but
the way you were saying about your
savings how you're like oh my gosh it
just it feels like it may just take a
little bit so have some patience yeah
but we're gonna put in the show notes
our Ramsay relocation guide that's a
link and that's going to go through and
walk you through a big checklist uh when
you are relocating but I think that you
guys have
um another step I mean you're going to
relocate but before home ownership comes
in I would do these other things first
yeah and I would take I would take the
word payback out of your vocabulary like
with that with that money like I think
that just having that like that is a
gift and if it's a gift like put it in
your emergency fund like Rachel said and
don't have that that feeling of you know
you owe them for some reason to allocate
it a certain way
um I think that they still would be
rooting for you to get your fully funded
emergency fund so that you can be secure
when you do purchase a house and I would
also just say like slow down I think you
guys have been through so many big
transitions going from the mission field
now you're in Washington state you're
going to be moving you don't have to
slow down the moves but the the feeling
that you have to purchase a house and
you have to have everything sorted out
just the fact that you're coming to
Nashville that's a huge transition
and I think yeah and I know my husband
he because we've we've rented and he's
very passionate about like you know he
wherever we want to live he wants that
to be an investment so my my husband
hates renting because he's like he feels
like he's just throwing his money away
and yeah that's how I kind of feel
sometimes too so that's why he's pretty
dead set on I don't want to move to
Nashville unless like we have a house
and I'm like they realize how hard
that's because of me but trying to you
know are there any banks out there that
offer like relocating loans with a very
small down payment or not even a down
payment I don't even know what's right
you guys are broke all right Lorraine
you guys don't need to buy a house right
now you don't need to buy a house you
don't have the money you don't but you
just asked to put nothing down on a
house all right it's just not smart I
understand what he's saying it feels
like you're throwing him anyway but
that's also wisdom there's wisdom in
this okay and you guys how old are you
guys
um 26 my husband's 28. okay so listen
you have a long life to live to be a
homeowner and I'm all about home
ownership we took a call in another
segment that I'm like I I think
homeownership should be part of
everyone's financial plan because it's
smart it's smart to own a home and build
equity all of that
but it's when you're ready if you guys
rush into this Lorraine it is going to
be stressful you're moving to a new
place you guys are you don't have a job
yet the the tension within your marriage
everything starts to just feel like I
can't breathe all because quote unquote
we didn't want to throw our money away
for a year breathe just like Christina
said just slow down I'm begging you slow
down you guys are gonna be okay you're
gonna buy a house one day it's in there
it's in the future but don't rush this
this is a really really big big decision
and Lorraine hang on the line we're
gonna pick up and give gift you FPU so
you all can kind of walk through the
steps and figure out what slow looks
like slow and the right way to build
wealth in the long run we'll be right
back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
with debt payments and now inflation
stealing more and more of your paycheck
we know a lot of you feel like you're
just drowning you're scared and you want
to take care of your family but you feel
like there's just not enough money so
listen you do not have to live with that
kind of stress but it takes this I've
had it moment to try new things because
change and trying new things are scary
right we are comfortable with what we
know so in order to change we have to
have this moment of I'm done I'm done
with this and if you're there that means
it is time to try Financial Peace
University this is our nine lesson
course that'll teach you how to beat
debt and build wealth it's everything
you wish you had learned about handling
money when you were younger you're like
where was this class I should have had
this earlier now nearly 10 million
people have taken FPU and they will tell
you that they don't worry about money
like they used to they are in control
and that can be you too so if you are
done stressing about money take control
and start Financial Peace University at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramsesolutions.com
FPU up next we have Paulie calling from
Denver Colorado hey Polly welcome to the
show
hi thank you for taking my call thanks
for calling how can we help
um just uh well I retired a couple years
ago and so I'm like on half the income
that I usually have and my husband is
still working he's younger than me he's
probably got another 10 years while
he'll be working
um we have a 401k I have a paid
retirement benefit but I had a little
bit in a 401k so I I already invested it
and I just kind of want to forget about
it and let it do its thing for a while
but in the meantime we have
um debt and um I've kind of been living
off my car just because we go paycheck
to paycheck and um I'm trying to put
together a budget and there's just a
couple things we had like a eight
thousand dollars put aside for Home
Improvements but it's been sitting there
from an old refi a couple years ago and
since we're not using it I wanted to put
it towards my card
um and get my balance down but uh then
he mentioned well we're going to need to
pay taxes and it might be around that
amount too so now I'm not sure if I
should use it to get my card down or if
I should
see what we owe in taxes and maybe use
it for that okay but with such high
interest on the cards I I figure it's
it's got to be better to get that debt
down but in the process I also found out
that he's maxed out his cards so I'm
guessing we're somewhere around 30 or 40
000 in debt
okay so let's let's um pan out just a
little bit Paulie okay so you are
retired you said you were are you
pulling money from retirement everyone
you said you're making about half of
what you did or is that yeah in a pit
Okay so
um I'm making uh 36.50 a month and
um
and how it brings in somewhere around
5500 a month and he brings it 5500 okay
um hey Polly before we get too deep into
like the Tactical what we do with the
money where your money goes are you
still spending on the cards
yeah yeah so
um it just seemed like every time I went
to use our so I have a separate account
because of uh something that happened in
2015 he thought he was gonna leave so we
were separated for a while so I went
ahead and got my account for my own
safety to have money okay
um now we still have a joint account
we're back together oh you know it's
it's good
um but uh he's not on the same page with
with the whole financial thing I think
he's still thinking you know he's
working full-time he's doing really well
he's you know
um but you're still spending on the card
too right like you said that you're
living I want you to cut those cards up
tonight like get your scissors out and
cut them up tonight
yeah because if we pay it off if we use
that eight thousand dollars and pay it
off and you're still spending we're
going to be in the same situation in six
months
yeah yeah absolutely
um so step one stop the bleeding
yeah exactly
um but that takes care of mine but not
his and
um I'm trying to get him on board and I
was hoping the day was there so you
could tell me how to talk to a man about
finances without them shutting down well
Rachel's pretty good about you know
couples and money yeah
um
okay so Paulie
for you guys you do you still have a
separate accounts or are you guys
working out at the same account
well we have a joint account but
um that I have access to but then I have
a separate account and I've got a couple
thousand dollars saved but I'm gonna put
at least a thousand of it towards my
cards
um I've rolled up all my change I've you
know I'm trying to sell things okay so
let me let me kind of pan let me pan uh
I just want to get a full picture of you
guys as a couple so we'll we'll not
pretend that it's all separate so all
together you guys okay you see you're
making a little less than 10 grand a
month how much debt do you guys as a
couple have
I think it's going to be anywhere
between 30 and 40. I know mine is 19 and
I'm just guessing Okay yeah and that's
all on credit cards
yes okay do you have any cart do you
clean a camper
um our cars are all paid off right how
much how much is the camper
how much you have left to pay for it or
pay on it two or three I don't remember
what the payment is and I still need to
find out some information from him
because he does all the okay bills but
I've been trying to put together a
budget
um it was forty thousand dollars uh a
couple years ago so I imagine we're
paying at least a couple hundred on it
okay
um any other any other debt what do you
guys own your home
uh Wheels 411 and it goes anywhere
between 500 and 624 when you look at the
value online okay
but we've worked refinanced too many
times yep yep okay so here's the deal
Polly we are going to help you
tactically
um we're gonna give you Financial Peace
University we've been giving away all of
this show but really if you can get your
husband you guys to do this together
these end lessons tactically it's going
to help you walk through all of this but
I think the I think one of the bigger
problems is is that you know in a
marriage if one person is trying to you
know fill in the whole of debt to get a
you know a a flat ground level uh you
know of trying to get out of this
financial hole but the other person is
digging out the bottom
then then yeah it's not going to work
right and that's why we really stress
for couples to work together so I know
that he's hesitant but there has to be
something in him Paulie that knows we're
not in a great situation my wife is
retired I'm coming up on retirement age
here in the next decade we still owe 411
000 on our house we are living paycheck
to paycheck we are depending on credit
cards we have we have 40 000 of credit
card debt we have a camper like all of
this there is a level to him that's
going to feel that he knows he knows I'm
sure deep down and so what you want you
to talk about it and that's it so that's
that's where we always say it's not just
a money problem there is a marriage
issue that you guys are not United and
probably not just in money and other
things and so if you do have a great
um Church in the area or a great
therapist marriage service I mean I'm
not kidding if there's any way to go and
get a third party involved this is the
time to do it because as you sitting
there trying to convince him may or may
not work I don't know I don't know your
marriage but I think unders for him to
know where you're at all you can do is
control you and Paulie I think it would
be a probably a helpful conversation and
a very maybe intimidating and vulnerable
conversation but to come to him and say
hey here are the numbers that I've seen
I've tried to pull you know what we have
and this is the situation
and I am scared I am freaked out I feel
like we should be further along than we
are at our age and I don't know what to
do and I I would love it and long for
you to come with me on this journey and
us do this together because I want our
future as a couple to be stress-free and
to be bright and to go and doing these
incredible things that we want to do at
retirement this is what we want to do
but I think what you're going to start
to find is that there's a lot of
marriage stuff under that that you guys
may need to heal from that 2015
situation that happens and I think
that's a great thing but starting out
this and opening the door when it comes
to money and that conversation I think
is really really important Polly but
well I think you need to take ownership
for your part in it you're not he's not
the only one digging this hole you're
digging it too and you need to stop with
a credit card and also just look at you
and what you can change we'll be right
back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey show our
scripture of the day comes from proverbs
10 12. hatred stirs up conflict but love
covers over all wrongs our quote of the
day is hate is too great a burden to
bear it injures the hater more than it
injures the hated that is Coretta Scott
King wife of Dr Martin Luther King Jr
all right Rachel I want to go back to
that last caller really quick and just
kind of wrap that thought up so she
mentioned she wished Dave was here so
that she could have a man's perspective
but as I thought about it I'm like I
think if Dave were here he'd kick her
butt he would be pretty frustrated
because she's sitting there talking
about her husband and what her husband
is doing wrong but she has more debt
than her husband and she's still taking
on more debt and I just think that's
such an important call out for couples
who are trying to get their spouse on
board with Financial Peace University
who are trying to get their spouse out
of debt make sure you are first setting
the example make sure that if you want
your spouse to stop using credit cards
that you stop using credit cards first
right yeah like don't just point and say
we need to make all these changes
because that basically what they're
going to hear is you need to make
changes I don't need to change yep yep
totally with her situation I know
there's like you said they need to go to
a counselor there's probably a lot of
trauma and fear in all of that mixed in
so yes that's all true but lead the way
yourself
show your spouse you know what you want
them to embody don't just point fingers
because that is going to be one of the
number one way man or woman is going to
put up a wall if you're just saying you
you and you're not looking at yourself
and saying how can I improve for sure
that wall is going to be up and I do
think Paulie what I was feeling too from
her I don't think she knew what I don't
think she knew what to do they're living
paycheck to paycheck
they have these bills all she knows is
to use a credit card do you know what I
mean like I think for her too
she was like I know I need out and I
don't know what to do to get out too you
know what I mean so that's why I was
like even tactically we can't like dive
in I mean what yeah you would cut up the
card you would say here's the here's the
budget and anything that once the money
runs out we're done like we can't pay on
anything else we're going to cut
expenses we're going to work ourselves
getting out of debt like that that's the
Tactical side that's how you do it
um which is you know and again we gifted
her financial piece university to do
that but I think yeah go ahead well I
was I was gonna just say that you know
in her situation and I think some
especially if you're a new listener it's
like okay I keep doing the same thing
over and over again this is the result
I'm getting I don't like the result I'm
getting so I what do I do next you know
I mean so I love the so I love that you
called it out though to say okay the
first thing you have to do is you have
to stop going into debt if you want to
work your way out you can't keep going
in well and part of it is to come at it
humbly say like I've screwed up I am
screwing up I'm spending on credit cards
you're spending on credit cards let's
lock arms and let's do it together like
before you worry about his reaction and
what he's gonna do like admit you know
I'm I'm overwhelmed by this I don't know
I'm scared I'm still spending on this
then what can we do together and make it
like a together Thing versus a you know
us you know your pointy fingers right
and we have a really great article we'll
Link in the show notes about money and
marriage so if you are kind of in that
situation and you're trying to figure
out how to navigate it with your spouse
check that out all right let's go back
to the phones next up we have Greg
calling from Virginia hey Greg welcome
to the show
hello ladies thank you for taking my
call of course thanks for calling how
can we help
my question I'm 59 years old uh looking
to build a house a little back story uh
my spouse and I have gone through FPU
I've coordinated it on four different
occasions
uh our income monthly oh you're welcome
a monthly income is north of 9 000 a
month bring home
retirement accounts who are north of
9.50
and that's invested in traditional and
Roth IRA 401K good for you Greg well
done
uh we're saving north of 6100 a month
nice
cash on hand is north of two hundred and
ten thousand dollars so your baby
stuff's millionaires yes ma'am
congratulations thank you it wouldn't
been for Dave and his teaching we
wouldn't be
uh looking to build a house that's
probably in that 650
000 range plus or minus
we bought property paid cash for that
we built a shop paid cash for that put a
road in
paid cash for that we put a septic
system has been installed and that was
paid in cash as well we just need to dig
a hole and build a house
uh I feel like a hypocrite you know
telling people to get a dead and being
successful doing so and now we're
looking at at biting off this chunk now
with our income and our commitment to a
budget and paying it back I suspect
we'll hold on to a mortgage
well no more than five years and it
would be paid off we have no other debt
uh aside from this pending mortgage and
I wanted your opinion as to whether
we're nuts or not whether you're nuts or
not
um well you know us we would always say
that the best way to buy a house is 100
down which I know is not realistic for a
lot of people
um but when it comes to a mortgage you
know well you know this Greg because
you've you've taught the class of the
15-year fixed rate all of it I mean but
you're well under that with the five
years of what you think you'll be able
to pay off what are you what what's your
house worth now
actually we sold the house we had it did
not have a mortgage we sold it for 440.
put the money in the bank uh and add to
it every month and that's how we've been
able to to pay for the land
of cash but adding to it every month
gotcha but but that's that's where the
210 comes from then correct okay I got
you I got you
um yeah I mean it will be hard beer and
baby step seven currently so you'll go
back a baby step
um
which again is like oh you know you you
hate to do that but we have talked to
people that they're like you know I'm
gonna take out a small mortgage and
we're gonna pay it off quickly and
here's the plan and here it is and so I
think Greg if that's what you guys
decide
um that you want to do you know that's
that's totally up to you guys I mean for
for some people they're like I never
want debt again like once I'm in baby
step seven I'm not going back but um but
we've had people even here that have
done that they've paid off their house
and they're like you know what we want
to upgrade a little bit so we're gonna
take on a small mortgage and do that
um and so where are you guys at where
you are financially I think you're in a
position that you can Greg I mean you're
gonna you're gonna be okay you guys have
done incredible with retirement
um the cash you have on hand you guys
are diligent Savers putting so much away
per month that you were saying and it's
going to be in five years yeah you'll
have it paid off so
um I don't think do you have a fully
funded emergency fund
and uh do we continue to save for
retirement uh I mean honestly right now
it's a match because we're both still
invested uh on my plan if I invest six
percent they match at nine that gives me
15 that you're 100 invested in well we
don't include the we don't include their
match as part of the 15 percent
understood okay
so should we bump both the virus up to
15 of this juncture I I my opinion and
I'm probably wrong here the more we're
saving for the time the less we're able
to pay cash on a house
and so it's kind of
it's it's probably a draw either way uh
I I just want to know what your thoughts
are please
oh okay um yeah I would say yeah
where you guys are with retirement the
amount that you have you know I mean I
would still hit that 15 if it were me
and then whatever you have left is where
where you would go for the house what
you would put towards the house
it's good Rachel
all right well thank you for your call
Greg we're proud of you for being a baby
steps millionaire and honestly I would
work through part of feeling like a
hypocrite is going to be if you keep
that private you're teaching your FPU
classes I'd be willing to share that I'd
be willing to say hey y'all this is our
situation and we are we're in it with
you again we are going to be paying off
this debt we're going to be working
through it and just be honest about it
part of that icky feeling that you might
feel as if you feel that shame and
you're like oh I can't share this
because it's going to change things
it's not just be honest and then you're
back in the FPU class and you're with
them through this process that's right
and y'all I just want to call out we've
got a Ramsey Solutions newsletter if you
all are worried about Heating and gas
bills the newsletter this week is going
to be 11 ways to save on your heating
bill so go to
ramseysolutions.com
newsletter that puts this episode of the
Ramsay show in the books thanks to the
people in the booth Emily Ben Austin
Zach and Andrew and to you America for
listening we'll be back soon this is the
Ramsey Show
thank you
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]